una odisea para huir de la guerra hace
dos semanas javier 2 lukasz pelayo lo
dejo todo atrás en kiev se trata de un
músico mexicano que junto a su esposa y
su hijo de 3 años logró escapar de los
bombardeos
y llevó una bitácora de la travesía
bueno ya estamos acá más cerca de la
frontera
ya trajimos a nuestra familia y
probablemente ya vamos a salir javier
vivía en ucrania hace varios años allí
era director de una escuela de música
logró llegar a su país en un avión de la
fuerza aérea mexicana procedente de
rumanía que llevaba a 81 personas
evacuadas por nuestra casa nuestro
departamento con muebles con todo lo que
es una casa normal
y
y pues tuvimos que dejar todo hasta los
peces y lo que teníamos ahí los
animalitos se dice quedaron
pero logramos salir con vida en regimos
puse una maleta con documentos y un
poquito de dinero del que yo tenía
ahorrado en efectivo así como el
millones de personas han huido de la
guerra
hemos superado otro hito terrible 3
millones de refugiados han huido de
ucrania la guerra tiene que parar ahora
al menos 14 millones de ellos son niños
según la agencia de la onu para la
infancia unicef mientras que 157 mil son
ciudadanos y terceros países de acuerdo
con la organización internacional para
las migraciones
más de 18 millones han cruzado a polonia
más de 450.000 estará en rumanía cerca
de 337 mil en moldavia casi 264 mil en
hungría y unas 213 mil en eslovaquia
además más de 140 mil habían ido a rusia
y más de 1400 a belarús según cifras de
acnur